So now you're going to go ahead and
create the new composite indexes. So first of
all, open datastore-indexes-auto.xml. You may find it's blank.
You may find it's got some content in it
already. Either way, it's fine. Then, run the
query on localhost. Then go back to Eclipse
and check the datastore-indexes-auto.xml file and you should
find that the new composite index has been automatically
added to it. Now that you've updated the
index file, go ahead and deploy your app
to appspot. In the developers console, go ahead
and look in the Index Viewer. Is your
new composite index preparing? You might find that
it's already ready and that's just fine if
it is. When your index is ready, run the query and make sure that it works.